The new climate crisis warning.
A study says the Arctic
could be free of sea
ice during the month of September,
about a decade earlier
than previous projections.
And this would have dire
ripple effects right around the world.
The scientists findings are published
in the journal Nature Communications.
They want the first September one
report to completely melt
the Arctic Sea
ice may happen by the 2030
that's earlier than anticipated.
And this could happen
even if the world made significant cuts
right now to planet heating pollution.
Our chief
climate correspondent, Bill Weir,
joins me now from New York.
And Bill, so anoxic with no sea ice.
What would that mean?
How would that impact us all?
It would have so many impacts.
It's kind of important
to think about the Arctic
as the immune system for planet Earth.
And if it goes,
it makes all of our problems
get much worse, much faster.
We've known
it's been heating up there
four times faster than most of the globe.
20, 21.
It rained at the highest peak
in Greenland for the first time.
Last year.
A hurricane
managed to push warm air up there
and created this late melting pattern.
Now, looking at the numbers
in the satellite
that it looks like
it's losing
about 12 to 13% of sea ice per decade
in September there.
And I think we have animation from NASA
that just shows a timelapse
from satellite images
of just how dramatically it's gone away.
And the main factor here
is that all that white ice
is reflecting sunlight
and deflecting all of the sun's energy
there that open water dark water absorbs
kind of the way
a black dashboard in a car
would at a much higher rate.
And so it is yet another reminder.
Now they look at the models.
Even the
IPCC's latest state of the science report
that just came out
predicted middle of the century
before we'd see an ice free Arctic.
And now to says this new examination
looks at the old climate models
and it looks like
they were just conservative.
And it's going to happen
more dramatically than we thought.
And so
but ten years earlier,
that is a significant difference
from what we've been expecting.
So why is it happening so quickly then?
It is
the combination of just unchecked
planet cooking, pollution, just building
up, building up.
It is more
and more of the reflective
ice going away.
So it's heating up faster.
It's also ocean currents
and atmospheric things
wobbles in the jet stream
that we're just now understanding
because they're brand new to science.
And so you hear a lot of this surprise,
but this will also change
human behavior the way it always does.
People, shipping
companies will now
see the Northwest Passage
as a more viable route
instead of going south
to get around the world
some see profit in a melting Arctic,
even as it seems to be a huge
red flag to scientists.
And if we then make significant cuts
to fossil fuels,
the conversation that you have had
and I have spoken at great length
about will that change anything?
Could this turn this around?
Could it delay it
Yes.
I mean, that's the one variable
that's the one
lever humanity has is stopping
the rate of that pollution emission.
Right. Now.
And, you know,
the argument is from some as well.
We may be past certain tipping points.
Why bother
or it's too big of a challenge.
Every 10th of a degree
could be the difference
between the landscape
you grew up on, living or dying.
It could be the difference between
coral reefs existing or not entire,
you know, species
or green belts
and all the things that go with that
in terms of peace and prosperity.
So, yeah, that is the that's the lever
to grab
What it shows
is that we're definitely behind
the curve, right?
We're definitely behind.
We need to be doing more.
Bill, we're always great to see you.
Thanks, Bill.